on passe de la musique au rire aussi
c'est aussi de la culture et y a un
festival qui va s'ouvrir dans quelques
instants si vous nous suivez ce soir en
direct il est presque 19h c'est le
festival du mour de roconcours
exactement alors nous avons rencontré
Susanne Drouet qui est la
vice-présidente du festival et qui va
nous expliquer comment elle a
sélectionner les artistes et surtout en
quoi ce festival est aussi un trempelin
pour eux alors on va
l'écouter il faut que ça soit ça sort de
l'ordinaire il faut qu'ils aient une
présence il faut qu'il euh c'est un
mélange vous savez pourquoi vous aimez
un artiste et pourquoi un artiste
réussit c'est parce que justement c'est
un mélange de tout ça c'està dire chacun
a son potentiel parce que nous avons
choisi des artistes qui ont vraiment un
potentiel le tout est de savoir s'ils
sont encore assez mûs assez mais en
général oui ça ça ça marche très très
bien sil se révèle pas dans l'année il
se révèle dans l'année suivante quand
les artistes sont passés chez nous euh
il y a un tout un un réseau de de
communication dans les ivelines où
toutes les les communes qui veulent
participer invitent ces jeunes acteurs
et ces jeunes humoristes à des soirées
humour ce qui fait que non seulement le
festival leur permet de de passer sur
une scène mais en plus d'avoir des des
des engagements des engagements et des
cachets dans toutes les communes des
ivelines donc c'est très très important
et oui et nous avons aussi rencontré
Patrice Lafond qui est le président du
jury de ce festival et qui va nous
livrer avec humour mais à certains
second degré euh bah ce ce comment dire
que ce que représente pour lui d'être
président et surtout là aussi ce ce
qu'il attend de ces humoristes on
l'écoute je crois que je serai assez
consensuel et que j'écouterai beaucoup
ce que les autres ont à dire je pas je
seraai pas un président qui tape du
poids sur la table simplement ça m'est
déjà arrivé dans d'autres j'ai j'ai fait
d'été précédent de deux autres festivals
dont un important qui a Luu à Tournon et
je me souviens avir beaucoup œuvré pour
donner un prix à un jeune que je
trouvais très intéressant et
qui n'avait pas l'air de plaire beaucoup
à mes camarades du jury donc là j'ai
fait jouer ma voix prépondérant par que
j'avais deux voix je sais pas si c'est
le cas encore là
et donc j'ai beaucoup assisté finalement
on l'a pris et il n'a fait aucune
carrière donc peut-être que je me
demande si j'ai le pif quoi je vais être
spectateur parmi d'autres sauf que je
serai président et qu' aura quelques
égards pour moi
simpement
mais je m'en prends pas du tout au
sérieux moi j'aime bien l'humour second
degré
euh j'aurais tendance à ve dire le texte
ne suffit pas faut que ça soit bien
interprété il y a souvent des gens qui
ont des texes des textes plutôt
originaux et plutôt bien fait et plutôt
bien écrit moi je veux que ça soit bien
écrit je veux pas la vanne pour la veine
ça m'amuse pas trop je veux qu'il a une
progression et en plus je veux que ça
soit bien joué donc vous voyez ça fait
beaucoup de choses quand même donc la
personne qui réunira ces différents
critères aura une chance d'avoir ma voix
un président qui va pas falloir décevoir
he lors de ce festival decours et il
sera aussi sur notre antenne dans les
prochains jours exactement donc on
pourra le retrouver dans le cadre de
l'émission de Patrice carmous vyp dè
vendredis VIP on va regarder un extrait
de l'un des artistes qui se produit
justement ce soir sur ce festival de
reconcours c'est Alex visorek extrait de
son sketch les S
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
balles
[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez entendu ce morceau
magnifique ce morceau magnifique moi je
l'ai entendu pour la première fois dans
la salle d'attente de mon
proctologue la vie est tellement injuste
mon proctologue est
méloman une fois ma consultation
terminée consultation qui ne restera pas
dans les
anales il n'a rien
décelé parfois il décède
parfois
pas toujours est-il que j'avais besoin
de me changer les idées quand on quitte
son proctologue on ne pète pas la
forme j'ai donc décidé d'aller à la FNAC
pour acheter ce morceau et là quel
bonheur se balader dans le rayon musique
classique de la Fnac j'ai l'impression
d'y dégager une intelligence
insolente les gens des autres rayons me
regarde avec
admiration ceux du rayon chanteuse
québécoise ceux qui pensent qu'André
Rieux est plus violoniste que
hollandais ceux qui s'imaginent
qu'acheter un disque deuts grammophone
est un acte profondément antisémite et
et moi j'ère dans les rayons avec
aisance alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
les bacs Jean
Sébastien Alex visorec un des artistes
qui se produit ce soir au festival de
reconcours le festival qui se déroule
jusqu'à vendredi et le résumé de la
première des trois soirées ce sera
demain soir puisque vous allez y
assister dans quelques instants
exctement nous ver les trois candidats
en liste ce soir les trois candidats qui
s'affrontent puisqu'il y a une place à
gagner avec une finale et une
représentation globale qui aura lieu au
mois d'avril et que vous pourrez suivre
bien sûr sur notre antenne c'est la fin
de cette édition du 78 la fin donc de la
chronique culture Aurélien on vous
retrouve mercredi prochain moi je vous
retrouve dès demain 18h avec de nouveaux
invités toujours en direct pour un point
complet sur l'actualité locale je vous
renvoie aussi à notre site Internet pour
revoir tous nos reportages nos
interviews et puis aux réseaux sociaux
Twitter notamment pour commenter le 78
avec le hashtag le 78 à demain 18h
[Musique]